et la situation sanitaire en russie si
le nombre de contaminations commence à
diminuer le taux de mortalité reste
élevé dans le pays ont fait des points
depuis moscou avec notre correspondante
verhaeghe hoffman
819 mordu coronavirus la russie
renouvelle encore fois son record de
décès hier le chiffre était à la hauteur
de 815 avant-hier 808 personnes décédées
à moscow l'épicentre de l'épidémie en
russie les autorités expliquent le
niveau élevé de mortalité par la
propagation du variant delta ii
coronavirus ainsi que la chaleur
anormale qui règne depuis deux mois dans
la région écoutez cette dynamique est
liée à la forte augmentation de
l'incidence de l'infection due à la
propagation d'un nouveau variant de
coronavirus en juin ainsi qu'à la météo
anormalement chaudes dans la ville ces
derniers mois la chaleur anormale a
affecté négativement la gravité de
l'évolution de la maladie chez les
personnes infectées par le coronavirus
comme ses conséquences et a conduit à
une aggravation en premier lieu des
maladies du système cardiovasculaire le
taux de mortalité dû coronavirus à
moscou au 1er août 2000 21 ans est le
suivant
2,93 % si l'on ne tient compte que des
cas où le coronavirus était la cause
principale
3 95 % si l'on tient compte de tous les
cas où le co vide était la maladie
principale ou concomitante selon les
autorités sanitaires de la capitale les
taux de mortalité sont en retard de
quelques semaines par rapport au pic de
k2 coronavirus le chiffre record de
contamination à mouscron était
enregistrée en juin 2021 lorsque le
nombre quotidien de nouveaux cadres de
coronavirus était à plus de 9000 la
russie recense plus de vingt deux mille
nouveaux cas de coronavirus chaque jour
dont près de 2000 à moscou la baisse des
contaminations des hospitalisations a
conduit hier le maire de la capitale a
levé une série de restrictions
sanitaires dans la ville